[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much Karolina also hello I
hope everyone is doing well after the
break and the cake and that was great so
thank you so much to the people who have
agreed to be on this panel we have James
at the end there Dominique yen
Myles and Maggie and yeah let's started
with this it says everyone has a mic on
yes yes hello hey we all have mics this
is going to be really exciting I think
the question that a lot of people if
they haven't heard about p39 the first
time that they thought was on the
schedule they're going to be wondering
what is this thing who would like to
take that on
so tc39 is the Standards Committee that
defines JavaScript so it's been around
basically as long as the language has
been we meet every two months for three
days and we talk about potential changes
to the language so this is the group
that designed es6 and it's also designed
async/await
the spec is designed on github and yeah
the other thing is t39 works on
JavaScript standardization which is
distinct from web standardization which
is done by other standards org so you
know a lot of the API is that you use
maybe or maybe you're not sure you know
set timeout often people aren't sure but
that's actually a Web API the things in
the JavaScript language are actually
pretty small and so we're focused a lot
on language features syntax in a very
small core library I think one thing
that I that I heard also was like
javascript is really a standalone
language it is used on the way
but it's really like something that you
can use anywhere maybe one thing that
people might be interested in is like
what is the standard actually what does
that mean Oh senator it's just a
document that describes what is what a
certain thing is what's supposed to
happen when you execute some code in the
example of in the example of a
programming language standard really
takes relevance when it corresponds to
implementations when it's a design that
everyone agrees on and that people can
actually take advantage of there are
lots of standards that you can find if
you search around and some of them are
outdated and some of them were just
fantasy
I think the JavaScript standard that GT
39 produced does a really good job of
striking a balance between continuing to
add new things and also maintaining
relevance through certain processes the
term standard tends to be overused in a
lot of contexts it's essentially a
document that describes the way
something should happen it's not
necessarily it doesn't necessarily
describe the way to actually happen the
way the implementers have done it but it
is the set of rules for you know if
you're going to do this do it like this
the other cool thing about JavaScript
having a standard and having a pretty
solid one is this is actually unusual
among a lot of languages so you know
languages I hope I'm not in accurate
here but my understanding is languages
like Ruby and Python do not have a
standard they have they have the
original implementation and everybody
who wants to have like something
compatible with those just kind of
reverse engineers it and and you know
maybe this is okay for a server or
mostly server language but for something
where we have four independent competing
implementations at least in the browser
and elsewhere it's really important to
have a central document that says
everybody should should be working the
same way some things that's particularly
unique about Java Script standard is
that the standard actually leads the
language so the c-sharp programming
language I work for Microsoft
so tons of interaction with that net
they have a standard as well but they
actually make the standard after they
create the programming language and in
JavaScript we have the opposite
happening we create the standard and
then the engines pick it up and
implement it so that's a very unusual
characteristic that has to do with the
nature the web so I think it's also
really interesting that you mentioned
that you're working with Microsoft but
on the on the tc39 which stands for
technical committees 39 you are
represented with jazz foundation right
can you talk a bit about how you got
involved in in the committee and also
representing the group that you do sure
so one thing everyone should know is
that some people up on this stage do
have academic backgrounds in language
design and extensive work there but that
not like a requirement for tc39
for me I am a very average full stack
web developer for Microsoft
I work in crisis management it has
nothing to do with his language design
at all I'm nowhere near the language
design teams at Microsoft and I maintain
moment je s the day time library and
what I found was that the reason moment
exists is because the date functionality
in JavaScript is very bad and I started
like running around Microsoft when I
first started working there a year ago
and I was like does anybody care is
anybody gonna fix today still broken and
nobody I worked that nobody did actually
Brian Charlson who's Microsoft's
representative to tc39 was like I care a
lot about that like when he and I found
each other he was like let's get this
done and so then at that point I had to
find a way to get there and the Jazz
foundation again the Jazz foundation is
a open source foundation that supports
the needs of many of the major open
source libraries in the JavaScript
ecosystem so jQuery all of the jQuery
family is under
foundation low - grunts webpack they're
all under jaya foundation and they said
if you care so much about the standards
we can send you to go represent our
libraries and that's how I ended up
there awesome thank you we have some
people who come who've been working on
the committee for like varying periods
of time so like Maggie you've recently
joined and we also have Dominic who's
been a part of tc39 for quite a few
years can you talk about your experience
joining and what was 5039 likes before
like yeah it's kind of funny to think I
guess I'm one of the people who spent on
the committee longest on this panel
there there is a lot of a lot of new
faces so I still feel like I'm
relatively new there there are a lot of
people who are on the committee and very
well established but my story I was a
web developer using using javascript got
kind of involved in in the language just
through curiosity as like oh I learned
about all these new features like when
are they coming what's the deal you know
I hear Firefox has like let and Const
what why arnt why aren't they in the
language eventually one area I got
really involved in was asynchronous API
s and promises and there was a push to
put these in in the web platform somehow
either through through the Dom API s or
through the language I thought it would
work really well in the language and I
live in New York there was a meeting in
Boston to stay there and I'm meeting and
so actually I took some time off work
took the bus up there presented my
written up you know fairly fairly formal
spec on how promises should work in
JavaScript and the committee was like
this is pretty good let's let's get this
into es6 so after you know that was that
was just the beginning of a long journey
and a lot of arguments on committee and
mainly arguments and and you know
promises were certainly not without
controversy but I think they've been
pretty successful and and after you know
I stayed involved I did this a lot of
this in my free time I got involved in
other web standards and eventually
Google hired me to to represent them in
teach through 9:00 represent them and
other web standards bodies and do this
full-time so
that was my journey pretty great I just
want to touch like super quickly on life
you're talking about getting features
into the spec can you say a bit about
that process like where do you start and
what steps do you go through to get
something into the spec yeah so there is
a whole whole formal process but to boil
it down to its essentials you kind of
the first step is to explain the feature
explain what it would look like you know
in use by developers what needs does it
address you know is this something that
exists in other languages what
cross-cutting concerns might have across
the rest of the language that exists and
and generally try and convince people
that this is a good idea and that your
solution to the problem is is the right
way to solve the problem and then you
kind of just advanced through the stages
of increasingly formalizing your
proposal writing actual spec text you
know bringing it to the committee and
getting it increasingly checked and
solidified along the way there's a
there's a multi-stage process where
their proposals put out there and in
order to advance the next step there has
to be a certain amount of implementation
experience right and as it advances that
the the spec needs to reflect what is
actually implemented so that way when it
actually you know comes out at the other
end you know that it actually matches
what users are going to be using out in
the out and out in the work out in the
world so and that somewhat new like es6
was the spec led the implementations now
they're much more in tandem which is
very healthy for I could go into that a
lot
I won't so we also have this concept of
a champion someone who picks up a spec
Meggy would you be able to think about
that oh sure
so the whole I guess reason that I ended
up the tc39 at all which actually is a
lot like Dominic's reason is that I've
heard a heck of a lot about one thing so
for the moment I am the champion or the
person who is responsible for moving
forward depicting of states in the
language
and I share that responsibility with
Brian Charlson at Microsoft and to get a
proposal move forward through the
process you have to find someone willing
to champion that proposal now many
people on TV 39 represent browser
implementers or other large corporations
so we have a few people from Google here
in my case I actually would be the
person who would represent you because I
represent the JAF Foundation which is
basically we think of ourselves as the
community at large but to get a proposal
through you need to find a champion and
that would be the person who either
represents you as part of your
organization Microsoft Mozilla Google
etc or if you don't have a large
organization duress then come find me or
Leo Bowser who also represents us
awesome so there are obviously things
that are under development right now
like things that each of you are super
excited about what is the most exciting
thing that's coming up in the next back
what's in development right now well for
me it's not necessarily what's coming up
soon is what already was developed and
that's module right I've been working
very hard with some other folks from the
node community to actually get modules
into node and they are coming it's going
to take a long time but they are coming
but yeah that's that's the thing I'm
most excited about seeing advanced yeah
like James coming from the browser
perspective I also am spending a lot of
time getting modules you know we put up
the syntax for them in es6 but no
semantics so you know saying modules
were any ethics is not really true in a
large sense so so we're finally getting
to that point I spend a lot of time on
that I've also worked on shared array
buffer which is the subject of an
upcoming talk we we have a lot of fun
again this is it's similar in that it
needs to integrate into the web platform
we need to say you know what threads can
you actually share this shared array
buffer between and that's that's not a
question for the language that's a
question for the thing that defines the
thread
web workers and so on the web platform
finally I'm also championing a proposal
called async iteration which we can talk
about more offline but I think it's
really cool well one smaller thing I'm
working on is features for regular
expressions this is this allows you to
do things like reference unicode
categories for characters in a regular
expression or also give names to groups
that are being captured and a couple
other things so I'm definitely excited
about that and and implementation is in
v8 behind a flag and I'm also working on
a specification for biggest four for
arbitrary size integers in JavaScript
with operator overloading okay I and
also some features for classes so I'm
definitely interested in getting more
feedback from this whole group on always
work on the big end stuff before the
classes so what I'm most excited about
right now is actually not a feature of
the language but alcohol feature of the
committee there's a lot of work going on
right now for a code of conduct within
tc39 and that is interesting because
many code of conducts are about conduct
of a community which is very different
than conduct of a committee so it's
interesting to try to reconcile the
differences between this and find the
language that that works but it's being
put through the process and I would say
I've only been to three meetings but
I've seen the conduct change just with
this being on the table suppose it's
obvious I'm excited about date I will I
do want to mention along with the t2
specification for the JavaScript
programming language tc39 also handles
Exmouth 402 which is the
internationalization API is like the int
L dot stuff coming from the date/time
space the moment Jo space this stuff is
really important I'm real
excited for everything that's going on
in antal because it's really going to
help people produce more global
applications that's fantastic we also
have a number of questions so we
outsource we sourced a number of
questions from you people the community
through this hashtag tc39 QF I'm just
going to read out a couple of them
because I think there are a few that we
can cover in the panel unfortunately
panels very short because like all of
these topics are fascinating and could
be a talk all on their own so we
selected a couple of those questions
that we could answer in the time that we
have and I'm just going to ask a couple
of them now so one of the questions we
were asked was what is the state of the
bind operator and what needs to be done
to advantage that came from Tobias Benny
ACK I'm going to mispronounce that I'm
so sorry all right I can take this on so
the bind operator is is a fairly popular
proposal briefly the idea is it combines
several ideas into one you want this
method chaining syntax so that you can
define things in another library but use
them as if they're methods on an
existing library so so that in another
language is Lensbaby this might be
called extension methods or something
like that and this is this is a pretty
great idea because then you could define
something like lodash but use it as if
it were on a native array as if they
were methods it also gives you syntactic
sugar for for binding and extracting
methods and a number of other things and
there's this variant of this there's one
that's a pipeline operator where the
bind operator uses this the pipeline
operator uses the first argument like
low - the problem is like it's this
complicated space with a lot of
decisions about well do we really want
to tie it to this or the first argument
do we we really want to tie binding into
the story or do we want to make it more
general and every time somebody's tried
to pick this up there's so many people
who feel the opposite way largely
largely in the community the committee I
think would be would be open to anything
if we had a clear signal from the
community in my perspective
it's been kind of discouraging to try
and get it moving forward the other
thing is we we just you know well we've
had champions but I think they've gotten
discouraged I don't know if that's fair
and dance estimation oh I just want to
phrase what Dominic is saying is this is
a big opportunity for community
involvement and whereas direction but
it's a positive where the committee is
definitely interested in this proposal
once we once we have more these kinds of
signals standards that are made without
community involvement are not just
scattered period I think yeah that's a
very good point because there is sort of
an issue with that how many people know
about the committee and they don't know
how to get involved with it and this is
also an opportunity for us to get more
people involved and James I'm actually
going to direct this at you because
we've mentioned modules and someone has
asked what is the status of es interrupt
module interrupts and it's been raised
in discussion many times and they're
just wondering what the statuses so this
is an area where the browser's are
definitely ahead of node I know that
there's there's still some variance in
there and the browsers and Dominic to
speak to that better than I could
as far as no implementation we're a long
way off for about at least a year and so
we have something that the community
would be able to work with we're working
on it it's going to get there it's a lot
of there's a lot more issues on the
servers on the node side that the the
browser's just when I don't have to deal
with so it's a lot it's a very difficult
technical problem once we get there I
think by the time we get there the
browser's will be like you know what
took you so long and we'll be able to
ensure pretty go to interrupt but yeah
yeah from the browser side we're trying
to do as much as we can to
to iron out the bugs in the in the
underlying infrastructure so that when
node is able to tackle it we can say
okay it's ready for you and again it's
just this multi-year process - you know
first we have module syntax and now
we're we're getting module semantics for
the browser but really you know
semantics aren't bulletproof until you
have them working in two environments
you know a single implementation of an
interface is not a great interface so
it's a tough a big challenge here also
is that equi - six - only defined like
the semantics of modules but nothing
about the semantics for loading and with
the browser and node being very
different environments there's different
constraints so the browser can't block
the main thread well while it's loading
everything so you have like this
asynchronous load phase before
synchronous execute operation whereas
the way require works is synchronous and
synchronous execution through the whole
tree is loading so this isn't able to we
can reconcile this but it's just it
breaks my brain and many people's reigns
and so it just takes a lot of time to
find a way to do it that allows both the
code in the browser and in node to run
similarly in what we want to avoid is a
case where you need to start worrying is
it running a note or is it running in
the browser I and I published a couple
of articles on this on medium there's
likely going to be another one within a
couple of months so small hand so yeah
that will give a pretty good update I
mean this is all topic that can take a
long time to discuss but please
subscribe to his newsletter also another
question that's coming up is will you
ever drop any features from JavaScript
now Ellington so from the node
perspective just looking at node just
note whenever we try to deprecated
something and even suggest that we might
remove something there's pitchforks and
torches and we go we have to go running
imagine that on the language level
probably not
yeah I mean think of it from a semantic
versioning perspective you know note
gets to make breaking changes it gets to
say we've implemented our major version
number and now you have to look at the
changelog and you know upgrade browsers
don't you know your browser just updates
every six weeks if you're lucky every
every six months if you're not and
there's no choice you don't get to look
at the changelog your users certainly
don't get to look at the change log so
we from from that perspective browsers
are always on major version 1.0 on the
other hand it doesn't operate on a
completely hundred percent strict you're
not going to see any changes that might
fray things es6 didn't make a whole
bunch of changes that did break things
and browsers had to come back and say
look we tried shipping this and it
actually broke things in a way that the
committee didn't expect because the
committee did didn't want to break
things it did want to stay compatible so
there was a sort of back and forth and
we arrived at a at a more compatible
version there but there are also cases
of breakage that are that are very
strange like adding a method to arrays
break is observed in some browsers to
break their users even if other browsers
don't find it to be breaking so what
actually is a simpler version Temper
major change that we can't do is a
little bit fuzzy but we're sort of late
like and you know these tiny changes
we're not going to like remove with or
belt bar or something
all right I think we're going to move
over to one of the one questions coming
from the communities that will also take
us into the next step which is what as a
panel or as ization or as people are you
doing to become more visible and better
connected to the community you know I'll
go ahead and take this one because this
is this speaks to how I actually got
involved last year well throughout
throughout node in tc39 s relationship
there's never really been a great
relationship there they weren't talking
to one another here you had the most
popular one of the most popular the Java
platform right and there was no
connection no communication going on
with the community or with the committee
and it really came to a head last year
but it's just a ton of talk about
hearing on Twitter which is always a
great great fun and we came to realize
that if Noth wanted to engage we needed
to actually you know show up in the
meetings get involved in discussions
provide feedback on the proposals as
they were being proposed it's a novel
concept it goes back to my earlier thing
it's candor without community
involvement is not good but we needed to
become involved and it was literally
just a matter of showing up so I think
something that a lot of people would be
interested in is like what as audience
members like what can they do to like
where can they go what can also myself
what can I look at what's a great place
to start getting involved well the
standard is developed both in these
in-person meetings and also on github
it's developed with patches you know
people can submit PRS we do have a
number of community contributors who are
not committee members who do submit DRS
and get real spec changes and really
help us develop a lot of the difficult
details with the specification that so
there's there's one main repository for
the the master spec and there's a bunch
of smaller repositories
for the proposals which are not yet
merged into the main spec in these
proposals it's great if people file bugs
or add issues or add comments to bugs to
give feedback on the proposals some
proposals are available in Babel or
other other cross-compilation
environments and you can use them to you
can use them in your own code and give
feedback to us based on that especially
if you can do it in github issues that's
the most that's the most accessible way
to proposal champions the github org is
tc39 so github.com /t 239 and I have to
say like I guess over the course of my
great many 3 years this has been a big
change like important both particularly
my enhanced energy source in general but
but just in pieces and I'm you know the
spec used to be developed in a Word
document
which the editor kept on his computer
and sent out to a mailing list once a
month so you know having it having a
visible change list process where the
community can submit pull requests and
file issues is pretty great I mean
there's a lot more we can do but I hope
that you know we're trying to meet you
guys
where you are and certainly where I like
to spend more of my days and instead of
my inbox so I'm pretty happy with with
the progress over the last few years one
place that you can look as well is tc39
slash agendas and on agendas you can
find the agendas of the next meetings
and this is a really great way to
discover what language features are
actively being developed and because
there's lots of different repos it can
be really hard to find a focus so if you
look at agendas you can find that we're
actually almost out of time there is so
much to discuss and
like there's so much that we want to
talk about so I guess the best thing
that we can do now is actually open up a
space where if you have questions
specific and then specifically to ask
then I believe we've chosen a location
to sort of sit for a bit
and take your questions and that was the
I forget what it will go to the
community all of us will be at the
community space afterwards and I think
we're going to go to the GCP booth all
of their stuff scheduled in the
community booth that we don't want to
over run little bit google booth goofy
yeah so head over to the google booth
and these wonderful folks will be there
to answer more questions there are lots
of topics there's also questions about
diversity work that's being done right
now to open things up more because the
tc39 has been around for quite a while
but there are certain pertinent
discussions that are still happening and
yeah make yourself if you have questions
come and ask and feel free to get
involved thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]